well mr javits pick for prime minister
liz truss is facing accusations of
grossly offensive remarks after
recording leaked of her saying that
british workers need more graft here's
exactly what she said
british workers um
produce less per hour than
and that's a combination of kind of
skill and application what needs to
happen is to me
more graft
uh joining us now someone i'm sure has a
view on that the shadow home secretary
vet cooper uh very good morning miss
cooper
let's start with that particular
recording you know you like me are
possessed of a regional accent i'm just
wondering why you don't graft as hard as
those down in the south east
you know it's a total disgrace what liza
truss has said i think it reveals what
she really thinks this comes after the
proposal she put forward to cut public
sector pay in the north and other parts
of the country so that in teaching
assistants or
nurses here in yorkshire would get paid
less than people in london or the south
east and she's also now just said that
people should be working harder outside
she has absolutely no idea that people
are working incredibly hard there are
people who are getting up to go to their
shifts right now
watching your program on the just before
they go to work working incredibly hard
to try and make ends meet who are facing
these nightmare inflation figures these
soaring energy bills and doing their
best to keep everything together and
just got this this insult that just
shows i think liz trust does not
understand working people right across
the country it's deeply wrong of her to
say this
and and of course everyone's going to
have to work that much harder now the
cpi figure out this morning 10.1
inflation
means that you know again uh wage growth
is just simply going to be outstripped
by inflation it it it's a reality is it
tenable in your mind that we are in
essence going to have to wait for the
emergency budget that will inevitably
follow whoever enters at number 10 on
the 5th of september or should we be
hearing more from the government right
now
we need urgent action we can't wait we
can't just drift while the conservative
leadership candidates just fight amongst
themselves we need action now that's why
labour's put forward this plan for an
energy price freeze so no one has to pay
an extra penny on their energy bills
through the winter because otherwise if
we don't get that action bills are
likely to go up by another thousand
pounds that is on top of the over ten
percent inflation that people are
already seeing and if you don't take
that action inflation is going to go up
even higher that's why we're saying act
now act quickly before the price
announcements about nine or ten days
time for energy bills in the autumn make
sure that people have got the
reassurance that they can actually make
it through the winter without ending up
being cut off unable to pay their bills
or unable to pay for their food
it's clearly not desperately surprising
that so many people are are in favor of
your policy indeed the majority of
conservative members polled uh peers
appear to agree that you know if they
can avoid paying a penny more in terms
of their energy bills that's the policy
they want but the criticism is
legitimate though that this is a
short-term measure it covers six months
it costs 29 billion pounds if you were
in government you'd undoubtedly have to
extend it another six months another 30
billion pounds on top of it and at the
end of the day you know party members
labour party members are asking the very
straightforward question if we were
prepared to pay this amount of money if
we were in government why not just
nationalize
what you've got to do is to something
very quick emergency measures that will
actually get people through the winter
because this is when we're expecting the
price rises to come
and that's actually the best thing to do
is to get those payments in place and to
get the windfall tax on the oil and gas
companies who are making record profits
make them pay their fair share by
extending that windfall tax and use that
to cut the bills so look there are wider
problems about the way in which the
energy markets work there's wider
long-term action that's needed in order
to cut energy bills for the long term
including insulating more homes
including introducing renewables and
including looking again at the whole
where the energy market works which is a
problem but none of that actually
delivers a fast action in order to cut
people's bills and that's why the
priority now is not about payments to
shareholders the priority now is about
action to freeze energy bills for this
winter but we think we find ourselves in
a situation where these energy companies
are enjoying despite the fact that
despite the fluctuations in the
wholesale price they are making record
profits to an extent and charging their
customers to an extent that already many
people are are struggling to pay their
bills now all this week i've tried to
get someone from the conservative party
to admit that this is clearly market
failure i can understand why they won't
but i also don't really understand why
when you're you're genuinely
prepared to spend you know 60 billion
pounds propping up the energy companies
subsidizing the energy companies that
nationalization isn't the first thing on
your lips in the way in which it was you
know when secure stamina came up with
this 10 manifesto promises
there's a total market failure and we
will set out what the response to that
market failure should be
as part of our longer term plans and as
part of the manifesto that we set out
for the government but anything around
looking at the ownership of companies
doesn't help you cut bills immediately
and that's why the priority right now is
to get that energy bill freeze in place
because obviously look you've got rising
wholesale prices
you've also got the need to take
immediate action because the bills are
going to go through right now before you
can do anything more so that's why we
set out a really simple policy just
freeze energy bills for this winter make
the oil and gas companies pay more be
prepared to take them on liz ross has
said she won't choose against even the
principle of a windfall tax rishi sunak
even had to be dragged into it so there
is a big divide here between labor
approach and the conservatives approach
that we really believe you've got to
have active government step in and make
sure those vested interests in the oil
and gas companies are actually paying on
those excess profits that have gone up
not because of anything that they've
done but because they are benefiting
from what's happening in this cost of
living crisis so it's right that they
should pay more but it's also right that
we should take immediate action to
freeze bills nothing else will actually
help people get through the winter i
mean let's trust is pretty explicit
about this i mean she says that the
policy of increased taxes on oil firms
profits may well put off investors
coming to the united kingdom she's got a
point
but these aren't profits that they've
made as a result of their hard work as a
result of things that they've done or
even things that they were planning for
these are talking about excess profits
that they've only made because of prices
shooting up because of global prices
going up as well and they are making
those profits as a result of everybody
else having to pay more in their energy
bills they weren't expecting these
excess profits you've got to take action
you can't just say it's fair for them to
get all these extra profits for not
having done anything any extra work as a
result
and people across the country to be
pushed into debt into poverty
potentially being cut off in their
energy supplies being unable to heat
their homes being unable to put hot food
on the table we've got to take that
action to support families right across
the country who are otherwise going to
be here by another thousand pounds on
their energy bills that is just wrong
government needs to act a labor
government would act we're urging the
conservatives to stop faffing around
and to take the action that we need to
support families now
yvette cooper thanks for joining us